dos meses más para el acuerdo de granos
en el mar Negro Ucrania podrá seguir
exportando de su importante despensa al
resto del mundo y Rusia sus
fertilizantes es un nuevo acuerdo con
Rusia negociado con Turquía y la ONU I
Welcome doy la bienvenida a esta
decisión la continuación es una buena
noticia para el mundo estos acuerdos son
importantes para la seguridad
alimentaria mundial los productos
ucranianos y rusos alimentan al mundo
de cara una segunda vuelta electoral el
presidente Turco acepta allí Perdón dio
la noticia en un mensaje televisado y
Espera que este sea el primer paso para
el final del conflicto
con suerte esperamos ver los días en que
la guerra entre Rusia y Ucrania resulta
primero en un alto al fuego permanente y
luego la paz
los alimentos y fertilizantes rusos no
han estado sujetos a sanciones sin
embargo sí que han visto afectaciones en
las restricciones de pagos la logística
y los seguros a la hora de poder enviar
nuestra evaluación principal de los
acuerdos Estambul del 22 de julio de
2022 no ha cambiado la hisparidades en
su implementación deben corregirse lo
más rápido posible
la invasión de Rusia trastocó la
alimentación mundial Ucrania era el
quinto exportador de trigo y uno de los
tres primeros de maíz cebada y semillas
de girasol la paralización de las
exportaciones afectó al precio de los
alimentos durante meses hasta que en
julio de 2022 se firmó un primer acuerdo
y tras varias extensiones Rusia había
amenazado con renovar el pacto que
expiraba el 18 de mayo Ucrania ha
exportado 30,3 millones de toneladas de
cereales y alimentos especialmente
destinados a países vulnerables